[Music]
[Music]
I'll be back
[Music]
- Oh Francie
why not just let me have her because
we're not machines
metal mother so my head this appointment
head that way
he doesn't tuck tuck pull the gun
[Music]
Arnold's back as the t800 we go further
with the t800 adopting human behavior my
past has caught up with me he overcame
his programming to take matters into his
own hands
to this movie I'm confronting things too
the more powerful dangerous
I love what they've done with his
character I'm going to help you protect
the girl because I choose to
I've saved three billion lives enough of
a resume for you this movie continues
the story of Sarah Connor that was
started years ago knowing the certainty
of the future to come this character is
a warrior for Humanity against machines
I'll be back this is a great kick-ass
action hero she's not waiting to be
hunted by a terminator she hunts to
death I am going to kill you you metal
no
expect a big pain brother whole body's a
weapons all right
this terminators do rev 9 the most
effective killing machines and the
franchise so deadly because it can split
and to two different entities
it is really scary his powers and
capabilities they're pretty damn
spectacular you can go into battle and
fight a rf9 but killing a rough nine is
almost impossible
never seen one like you before
almost human I am human just enhanced
McKenzie Davis's character is some
really interesting did she good is she
bad she's definitely not entirely human
she came to stand toe-to-toe with a
terminator grace comes back from the
future to ensure the safety of young
Dani Ramos you Dani
you're my mission she is the ultimate
protector
thanks lady don't thank me yet there's a
machine out there it was to kill me
thing is a really smart young brave
woman I want to spend and fight her
journey is much like Sarah's was she's
this woman who gets called upon to take
the reins in her own life and to act
bravely she's got the killer instinct
she doesn't think she's anything special
but she's obviously of great
significance in the future
because of me last night I was standing
there looking at a monitor on one camera
with Linda Hamilton and on another
camera was Arnold Schwarzenegger my
thought holy [ __ ] I'm making a
Terminator movie chemistry captured that
tone
it's r-rated it's grim its gritty it's
fast its intense
look hard and play hard and this is what
this video is all about in hostels fresh
vision and like what he did in Deadpool
is action is it's just a fast
white-knuckle ride you better watch your
ass I hunt terminators a metal
[ __ ]
but follows tonally in the footsteps so
t1 and t2 that adrenaline rush feeling
that sense of terror
in this film the action is 10 times
bigger it's like holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] this film is relentless it
just does not stop
just [ __ ] insect
dark state is the direct sequel
determinator to pick up the characters
that we knew from Terminator 2 and we
carry them forward we get to continue
the story with Jim backed and the
writing in the producing chair
he knows the material nobody else
I think for fans of the franchise the
biggest thing is that Linda's return
people love this character people love
Sarah big back is wonderful
Sarah's a force to be reckoned with and
I was ready to explore that I'm
delighted to work again with the
Hamilton the work with Cameron Tamela
played with all the new cast
there's new film is recaptured that tone
of those first two films it's gritty
it's fast its intense and it's just a
white-knuckle ride